All right guys.
Well,
thank you so much to coming to this talk at Google where we have the amazing
Hannah heart with us today who we know is everything from my drunk kitchen to
your hashtag no filter,
live series and countless other things.
Um,
I myself am an image irritative business partner at our alphabet company.
Verily,
uh,
my name is Brenna and it's so exciting to be here today.
Thanks for having me Brenna.
Ah,
the crowd goes wild.
It's not that way to send a Friday at Google,
right?
No,
I mean,
I mean for all of us,
we've got the weekend ahead of us.
So those true feeling good.
I mean,
weekend we weekend,
it's when we take off work for like 20 minutes and then we start up again.
Oh,
okay.
Someone's got to run the cadet.
He's the one downside of like living with your boss in your head because there's
no,
like,
there's no passage of time.
You're always at work.
I mean,
you gotta make your own clock.
Is that just like the hardest thing in the entire world?
Yes.
It's very hard.
I have a big God,
I have a team that helps me structure myself because structure is not something
I was born with.
An innate ability to do.
Oh my goodness.
And when you get into that in your book,
and I have to say,
I'm definitely gonna dive into doc cause there were some points in your book
where I was like,
I need some life advice and she's going to give it to me.
Um,
but I want to just get to where we are here today.
Here we are talking about your memoir and it's so vastly different than your
last book.
We had my drunk kitchen.
How did we get from that to buffering?
Well I would say that,
um,
with my drunk kitchen,
the cookbook,
uh,
it was really just like,
um,
the way I think of my dream kitchen,
cause I actually get asked a lot like,
oh,
are you always going to do my drunk kitchen?
Are you ever gonna stop making youtube videos?
And I always feel like that's like asking someone if they're ever going to stop
like tweeting or something.
It's like,
why?
Why would I like,
it's I love social media.
I love to share my experience.
I love to take snapchat pictures.
I love to post stuff on Instagram.
Like I love to make content.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a joy for me.
Um,
and so with my drunk kitchen,
the first book,
it was kind of like paying tribute to the reason that I got into where I was,
you know?
And also it was just a lot of fun to make and fill with awesome pictures and all
totally unique.
At the time of making the cookbook,
I was super proud of this.
They were all completely unique recipes.
Like I wanted to come up with new recipes instead of just regurgitating the
recipes from the series.
That was very important to me.
But yeah,
so my drunk kitchen will always be like near and dear to my heart.
I like to think of it as the phrase dance with the one that brought you.
It's like my drunk kitchen brought me to this wonderful ball and I'm going to
have a great time and dance.
A lot of dances with a lot of different people.
But my dream kitchen brought me.
So yeah,
going home with them.
I love that.
But and so you're,
you're buffering is a lot of your journals through the passage of time here and
as you're reading it,
you're going through so many different writing styles,
whether that's a poem to your first college lover or pros about your childhood
or your short story about you and your sister.
How were you able to bring all of that together into this cohesive memoir?
Wow.
That is a great question.
And also thank you for bringing that up and I really appreciate you reading the
book and like,
fantastic guys.
Read it.
A task book.
Okay,
good.
We got a good review.
Um,
we connected on a lot of levels.
You don't know this yet,
but,
um,
I think that what I really liked,
uh,
in writing the book is that,
you know,
the process of it was really different from how I thought writing a book would
be.
It was like,
it was like to allow myself to,
okay,
so let me get something.
You have to start from here.
Being authors,
not my full time job.
Right.
So like I have a day job of like my entire other career,
um,
going to,
uh,
Australia for the no filter tour.
Um,
she filming a movie called Dirty 30,
promoting that movie,
selling a TV show on food network,
making two videos a week and maintaining all the systems that run,
you know,
outside of the things that you immediately see about running the brand.
So we're writing though it is like my most near and dear most intimate form.
And the thing I love the most is really hard to carve out time for because when
you write,
it's not like,
oh I'm gonna write for four hours and I can guarantee the amount of work that I
will have done,
you know,
so I let myself just kind of do whatever I wanted.
Um,
and then with my,
with the help of my fantastic editor structure in a way where we found the
circle,
you know,
cause it was really important and this is something that having an editor was so
crucial for it because I'm too close to the experiences cause I'm trying to
write them as like detailed and like really pull you in.
So it's really hard to get a bullseye bird's eye view,
a bull's eye birds eye of the order that they should go in.
Yeah.
To come to a full loop.
The whole first pass of the book is actually in a different order because I,
to the delight of everyone who works with me suddenly realize things and then
need to restructure.
And so the restructuring of the book,
the chapter about Naomi was way early.
That's my oldest sister wait earlier on.
And I restructured the beginning journey and the end journey and I really,
really liked the way it turned out.
That's so funny.
I took note of that when I was reading it and got to the last chapter.
I was like,
I'm super curious.
And so there's a lot of thought there.
Yeah,
that's awesome.
It's great book guys.
Go Out,
read it,
buy it.
And I have to say,
so the title alone when you're talking about buffering and um,
for those we'll have the chance to read it.
It's processing and boundaries coming together and that is what buffering is.
When did you like come up with this Aha moment?
That was,
it seems so profound.
It's like,
oh,
thank you.
Well there were 90,
you know,
at around page 95,
um,
of writing of just like word,
gut writing.
I realized that what I was missing,
I was telling stories,
but I wasn't telling my story.
Like I was telling stories from my life,
So I thought,
okay,
how can I get back in?
And so I use,
so that's when,
probably around October I turned to the journals and I was like,
oh my,
like this is a brilliant structure.
This is about,
this is how I processed everything.
Oh my God.
Processing like buffering.
That should be the name of the book.
Like it was kind of one of those like thought processes where you're like,
this is exactly the perfect name because I wanted to merge the digital and like
the tangible and I want it to say these are the unshared stories I've shown you
what I've been comfortable showing you.
But these are the things that take more than 140 characters take more than a
four to six minute blog,
um,
to talk about.
And so that's,
that's how I came to the title buffering because it's that that wheel is that
boundary that allows you to fully process the data of your life before it's
something you're ready to show.
I really love that.
And I mean just talking about that,
going from a four to six minute flog or from a tweet,
your book is really intimate and it has a lot of secrets of your past and your
present.
How did it feel to just bear that all to your readers?
Ah,
well I think that the last week of my life has been so intense because you know,
when I've always used writing as an outlet.
So writing it out has always been really familiar,
you know,
because like I said,
always journaled.
Um,
I studied literature in college,
so I was really good.
Analytical writers are turning that analytical mind just inward and using it to,
to,
to realize what the crux of everything was.
And also just frankly,
the time in my life,
I've had away from a lot of the issues that are in the book.
Um,
but putting that all together and sharing it as been the most intensely
vulnerable experience of my life.
Like it,
we did a whole week,
we did a meet and greet before the book came out or assigning like the first and
second day of the book coming out.
Nope.
You know,
and the only a handful of people at the signing the day of had ad ready yet and
the signing the day before and nobody had even gotten it yet.
And then the second people started reading it,
it was like the energy of the signings changed.
I felt like,
you know,
people are like,
I read the book and it's like suddenly like someone being like,
Hey,
like I see you.
Yeah.
And it's the most incredible feeling in the world.
I think that anybody that grows up in a household where you have stuff that you
have to hide or whether or not,
you know,
you have to hide it.
You know,
inside you're hiding something and processing it and processing it.
Well that comes later in life.
But yeah,
exactly.
Um,
but you don't really feel as seen by other people,
you know,
like growing up you were like,
mom's crazy.
And I'd be like,
yeah,
I have no idea.
You know,
or be like this,
the excitement or it's like,
you know,
the holidays are like really stressing me out.
And I'm like,
yeah,
like,
you know,
it's trying to find,
I love connecting to people and I've,
so much of my life I've felt like I could see I'm trying to get in from this
side and buffering makes me feel like I,
I am or I'm seeing people that I didn't know we're hiding stuff too.
Absolutely.
Really that shared human experience and like you can feel it when you're reading
it.
It's just kind of like,
whether you're talking about coming out and getting responses from your,
your youtube family.
And it really seems like you've gotten an outpouring of just like support and
just like a lot of emotions,
a lot of emotions literally last night,
you know,
because it's like,
I like,
it's so intense to have people comfortable sharing things with you.
And I see a lot of it online and it's,
you know,
there's that distance,
there's that separation.
When you're reading something over text or reading a comment,
you're reading someone writing a blog post and tagging you.
It's,
there's a separation there.
But when you're in assigning line and you know that they know,
they know what you wrote in that book,
Nana,
um,
but people take that like 20 seconds and they tell you something incredibly
intimate about your life,
their life,
and then they thank you for helping them with that.
And it's such an honor.
It's just so,
it's like,
wow,
thank you.
I am so glad.
You know what I mean?
And all I did was just like,
really try and work on myself.
Selfishly,
I was here for me.
Yeah.
Or just like really just wanted to share and like it's the most incredible
connection last night.
I think it just kind of all hit me cause it was,
it had been one week or just about a little over a week and it just all hit me
and I just was like,
I was like crying but not like sad crying,
but just like,
like humans are so precious cross.
Like I said that I was like people,
wow.
It's an incredible feeling to be able to look at people and see everyone is
special.
Absolutely.
There were our most important resource.
We are.
Um,
and so it seems to be kind of just this trend in your life where it's sharing.
It's giving.
Um,
for those who don't know,
um,
my drunk kitchen came out of a love and a desire to help your friend Hannah Gal.
I'm just kind of heal,
um,
from across the country,
from New York to the bay back to the bay.
And so all of this,
all of that giving has reaped such success.
What are you hoping to see with this?
I mean,
you're shedding all of yourself.
I mean it's,
we're 10 x in here and the words of Google,
we are taxing.
I don't know what that means.
Doing it 10 times bigger.
Yeah.
Okay.
There you go.
I am Tedx thing.
I guess it's like,
I don't know.
Um,
I feel like,
you know,
my drunk kitchen created heart doe and buffering is allowing Hannah Hart to step
into the forefront.
And it's interesting because it's like,
I know what heart doe stands for,
right?
It's the idea to like practice reckless optimism,
which is,
you know,
I'm taking away all the naivety of optimism.
It's that you can be fully aware of your circumstances,
fully aware of the odds that are with her against you and you're choosing to be
positive about it.
You're like 70,
30,
huh.
Wow,
that's really hope.
Let's really hope it works out.
Let's do it.
We got 30%.
So yeah,
we've got 9%.
Exactly.
It's like,
that's reckless optimism.
I know.
Um,
and so now as like Hannah Hart,
it just kinda feels like,
like I don't know what's coming next,
but I'm really happy to be right here.
And so as long as I stay happy in the present or as long as I continue to pursue
like contentment in the present,
I'm voting things work out.
I mean that's all we can hope for the future though.
Right?
Really it doesn't exist.
I let,
let's say,
it doesn't live right now.
Yeah,
just painful.
Painfully existential.
It's true.
Well,
and in that,
in that same vein,
when you have harder,
when you have Hannah Hart,
do you think buffering was an opportunity to bring those two together?
Where you,
and I mean you've had so many life events that have happened recently,
whether it's you're coming out,
whether it's,
um,
really helping to save your mother.
Um,
do you feel that those two worlds are colliding to get now or are they still
separate in,
in,
in nature?
Wow,
that is a great question.
It feels like,
it feels like your childhood friend and your childhood best friend and your
college best friend or your colleague,
coworker best friend or like getting married.
You know what I mean?
And they're like the,
yeah,
it's like that because it's like,
it's definitely like a partnership is forming between those two sides.
If yourself are two different ways of knowing yourself,
you know,
it's when I meet people,
people like I feel like I know you,
you know,
and I'm like,
you do,
you know,
the last five years of my life and buffering is everything that happened before
that and everything that happened behind that.
Absolutely.
And so I don't know what this means,
like strategically,
but I do know that I feel,
I feel more like a balanced version might love myself and less like a
hyperbolized version of myself.
That being said,
I'm still gonna get drunk,
make a bunch of jokes.
I mean,
if you stopped,
I think everyone in this room would be very terrified.
Terrified.
I feel like what?
I mean,
there's nights where I tried to do the same thing.
I'm just not nearly as good of a chef.
I go back to that first episode right?
Where it's like,
I forgot I didn't have cheese.
Practice makes perfect.
It's weird.
Like,
I know so much more about cooking now and I've sold a show to food network.
I get to talk about food on it,
but I'm not gonna say anything more because I can't yeah,
shh.
Confidential.
Proprietary information.
Exactly.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
it's uh,
it's amazing what you don't realize you're learning because you're in the middle
of learning it.
That is amazing.
And I mean,
through your book,
you talk about kind of this,
this journey to find this balance.
Um,
and we have a room,
a company full of overachievers.
What has helped you the most really kind of find that work life,
personal balance,
personal.
No kidding.
Um,
uh,
well therapy obviously is really big.
Finding the right medication is really,
really big.
I use headspace all the time.
It's great meditation APP.
I have that APP as well.
Cause worse,
you should get it.
It's like headspace is really,
really great.
Totally.
Like,
you know,
not from a,
if you,
if you don't have a big spiritual or like you think religion is blah,
blah,
blah.
Headspace is the most like secular,
just like,
here you go.
This is the facts kind of APP for meditation.
Um,
but how do you find that balance?
It fills something I'm really working on.
It's kind of like going to the gym.
It's like sometimes you're like,
man,
I went to the gym three times a week,
month and I felt great and it was great.
It's like self care isn't something that ever stops.
And that's really frustrating because it's like you dip,
you're like,
oh man.
Like why do I like,
why do I feel so overwhelmed over here?
Like so sad over here,
you know?
And that's what's going to happen.
I think that balance is knowing that there are peaks and valleys and just trying
to lesson like the peaks and valleys between them.
Maybe take away the extremeness a little bit.
Yeah.
Eh,
well,
and it seems as though in,
in the past two years,
you've had a lot of,
uh,
come to truth moments,
when you're coming out and doing that.
So vocally I'm on the Internet.
How has that kind of being an out and proud Lgbtq plus plus plus individual like
help define your,
your next steps are or what's that like how was that for you?
Um,
it was a huge confidence builder.
I mean like it was amazing for me.
Like that's the thing too is that like people like I feel like everybody's like
thank you so much.
And I'm like,
no seriously guys,
I'm living my dreams.
I am so happy and I'm so blessed and I'm so lucky to be in the position I'm in.
You know when I did the coming out process was it was long and involved as it is
for many who have to come out about something.
And I also feel,
by the way,
this is just like something I want to say is that there are different things.
You can come out with yourself.
It doesn't have to just be your sexuality.
You can come out and be like,
you know what?
I think I might actually have depression.
I'm like,
you can come out and be like,
you know what?
I don't really know if this is the career path I want.
Like there's different moments of self realization that you have to have with
yourself.
Absolutely.
Um,
literally cause it's self realization but the,
with the coming out series,
you know,
I had my first,
I fell in love for the first time I was 19.
I took me like a year and a half to really accept that it wasn't a girl.
It was girls.
Uh,
um,
because that meant accepting my own heartbreak.
I would just go off,
I go into a lot and a great chapter called shadow boxer.
Really good title for that chapter.
Um,
and she mentioned that it's a self shadowboxing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Shut.
See,
beautiful analogy here.
It's
really good cause I onwards I loved it so happy so many times cause shadowboxing
is one word.
So many times I just headed back to the copy editor and be like,
it's one more know,
just put it one word.
Um,
so anyway,
the,
so from there it was like coming out to your friends and your immediate circle
of support,
like the people that you know will love you.
And then your extended family,
forget them.
Just kidding.
Um,
then,
and then choose your family.
So,
and then it was moving to New York because when I moved to New York,
I,
so I lived in San Francisco right after college.
I went to college at cal go bears.
Um,
and then I moved to,
yeah.
And then I moved to New York and when I got there,
you know,
this is the first time I'd ever left the bay area in my life.
When I got there,
they were like,
oh my God,
so do you have a boyfriend or what?
And I was like,
I was like,
no.
Also I'm gay.
Like,
you know,
and what do you New York,
think about that.
What do you person I've never met before and like I'm here on the east coast.
What's it like?
I grew up in the bay area,
you know,
which is like a very different temperature on a lot of issues.
Um,
and so it was coming out every day and those,
those moments.
But to answer your question,
which is a good one,
I feel so honored and privileged to be an Lgbtq.
I a plus plus plus plus role model and I feel a great responsibility to educate
myself and to open my heart and opened my mind to issues that don't only include
my direct experience.
Absolutely.
That's the edit,
edit all that other stuff out.
And I do think,
um,
your experience being a memoirs is so key here and talking,
I'm coming out about different things.
One of the things that I find so fascinating and kind of the Zeitgeists of
what's going on right now is more and more public figures like yourself who
outsiders see is so gregarious and you're funny all the time and you're always
on in,
in this book you really touch on like this very seriousness,
like openly admitting I'm an introvert and Amy Schumer's recently done the same
thing in her memoir.
What is it about this kind of like what seems like a dichotomy to your,
to your viewers and everything?
Well,
you know,
I'm a big believer in like the Myers Briggs assessment over the introvert
extrovert and assessment because like if I'm an extrovert,
then I'm an extrovert that spends a lot of time in their head.
If I'm an introvert,
I'm an introvert that loves the company of others.
You know what I mean?
Because it's,
it's more balanced than that.
So it's,
it's tough.
Um,
I guess,
you know,
for like,
if we judge it by on what recharges your batteries,
like I definitely need time alone to myself.
Yeah.
I really need,
and that's part of my self care.
I need to take walks,
I have to journal.
Like if I'm feeling like overwhelmed,
I really need to write it out and I know that I need to just spend time
centering.
Um,
I think that for a lot of public figures,
you spend so much of your life on export that you have to know what is your
version of import.
And there are some of us that work in this industry that their import is being
on a stage.
They love applause,
they love live performance.
I know a lot of people who are my friends who are like,
I gotta get back on on the road.
Like they feel stifled by having to spend all their time at home or onsets.
His civilian.
Yeah.
Well,
I want to get on the road like I need to like perform to a crowd.
I need to like see people.
Um,
so I think it really just depends on,
it depends on the public figure.
And do you find 'em,
I mean with your Hardo tour or Hello Hardo,
you were doing the habit heart day.
Do you find that that is part of your kind of recharge it,
it's so beautiful.
I'm so,
Hannah has this campaign where when she's on tour or she'll be doing or,
and it's continuing on beyond you.
It's continued behind on me.
In 2013 I ran a crowd funding campaign with Indiegogo called hello heart doe and
originally I was like 50,000.
It was going to be my goodbye tour for the record,
like,
and I go into that more in the book,
but it was going to be my way of being like,
Hey,
you know what?
I spent a year in La.
Not sure entertainments for me,
but I want to thank everyone that even gave me the chance to explore this career
path.
So I was going to hit 10 cities for $50,000.
And you know,
that's funny too.
In the end,
it ended up being 22 cities.
We raised over $200,000 and I,
we went to each of these cities across America and Canada and we'd arrive and we
would do a volunteer event at a local food bank shooting episode of Hello Heart
Doe,
the mockumentary travel show,
which is a great,
hilarious show that everyone should watch.
Oh man,
down.
It's okay,
dad.
Love them and leave them.
Am I right?
You guys?
Um,
they're called Lavs the uh,
and then she would never go to my drunk kitchen.
Yeah.
And in those volunteer days,
we called them,
have a heart days and it was our way of doing the meet and greet in the city.
And what was so amazing is that after hello heart ended,
there were cities that kept volunteering together because it was a wonderful way
to meet and make friends.
We have a great,
have a hard day here in San Francisco.
November 8th,
I believe is the next one.
If you're interested in signing up to volunteer.
Oh my God.
Well thought,
Kristen.
Our city captains the best.
We've got like nine countries and 36 cities that are currently active and it's
just,
it's,
it's just awesome.
I'm,
I,
it's like,
I'm so proud of it,
but it's not like I'm so proud of it.
I'm like,
it's bigger than we should be proud of it.
I love it.
Okay.
So,
uh,
we are going to break here for a few questions from the audience.
If anyone would like to ask a question,
um,
if not,
we're going to just close up here so we have anyone from the audience who's
interested.
Next one question.
There's a mic right here on them.
You get shot.
All right.
Um,
I shouldn't talked to
that way.
We can hear you on the interweb.
Yeah,
don't be terrified.
You don't want to forget my question.
Um,
my question is how did you find out what recharges you and like what was the
best self care?
Was it a lot of trial and error?
Did you like read some awesome books?
Was it three therapy?
That's everything.
That's a great question.
How did I find out what recharged me?
Um,
like what was my best way to recharge?
Huh?
I guess it's like,
how did I find out?
I guess it's just kind of like
partially observation.
Like,
you know,
like when you have people in your life that are like,
that,
that can see you when you can't see you,
you know,
and they like help remind you and you're like,
well,
okay,
like,
well then maybe I just really need to go take a walk.
Um,
I'm trying to think of like how I figured that out.
Oh,
I know how,
this is how
it starts with making your needs matter because your needs are there and so that
voice is always talking.
You're just not listening to it.
So if like we're doing a massive press day and there's going to be 10 outlets
that day and it's back to back to back to back.
I,
if we have a break,
it's like I would hear these needs,
I would just be like,
I really need some fresh air.
Like,
I really hope I can take a walk and instead of going shut up,
I would be like,
oh hey guys,
I'm going to take a walk really quick.
I'll be gone for like five minutes.
It's,
I think that that's part of it.
You just have to listen to the thing you're already telling yourself.
No,
hopefully
I love it.
So insightful.
It did.
It is,
it is.
Well to wrap up,
I mean,
here we are,
we're buffering.
What is still buffering?
What's next on the docket for you?
Probably
like sell probably like,
you know,
everyone,
I think you're always kind of on a journey of buffering.
It just depends.
You just enter into different stages of your life or at least that's what I hope
to do.
You know,
there are certain things that I know have stemmed from certain events in my past
and if I can recognize when that sort of reaction is happening,
I can take care of it.
I can,
I can start to calm it instead of letting it control me.
Um,
and so going forward,
you know,
there's the rest of life to live you now.
It's not always,
it's not always going to be like this,
so there might not be a future.
Let's live for today,
but we had even for today,
there's only today.
It's only now that that's true.
This is the coolest moment I've had.
Oh,
that's awesome.
But yeah,
every,
I guess everything,
you're always kind of processing,
but I'm ready to move into my adulthood and they let my childhood stay in the
past.
Therefore,
yes,
I love it.
Well,
thank you so much for coming to Google today and having this talk with us.
Thank you guys.